were you in a punk band when you were on  the same were you backstage with madonna  when you were in a punk band uh the the  punk band was in uh atlanta georgia okay  when i started out but in uh madonna  stuff that was new york in the early 80s  and was she  like a fan of yours uh no she was a fan  of no one's but madonna's yeah  she's she's only a fan of hers yeah  and still today still today  didn't you audition for madonna benedict  oh god yes i said  um and uh  yeah i i yeah she just sort of came in  breezily very late  and uh had a clipboard in handwritten  yeah  benedict cumberbatch is that really your  name and i went yes it is madonna  [Laughter]  [Applause]  i didn't get the part  [Music]